there's something else exciting wait a
second what's this one
ah wait a second should I do this one it
just started two minutes
it's a one-minute err hurry up in the
twitch chat
back-to-back tournament got a squeeze in
some water actually I'm out of water did
you probably look to see if there is
water in there first quick some votes
here about this tournament should I
compete in this one I go do it do
another okay three is a charm
here we go let's roll here oh wait a
second this is the guy this is the guy
that beat me in that one tournament okay
okay I have a nice structure right here
and I'm gonna look for tricks okay I'm
gonna run with this night out and clean
out here check is that correct
what is that King doin check where's
there a mate get over here tonight I
need the night around to give mate
come on night you know you want to give
me an F - how do you get there so quick
oh man let's give a check where's the
mate check and then here and then no
wait a second they're gonna give check
to me am I gonna get mated oh I think
I'm being mated let's come back here my
queen is actually gonna defend oh they
missed that is the King weaseling back
away not so fast
epic stopped him from going to h5 right
here is me is this mate
it's me back to tournament
okay five four three I have a lot of
catching up to do here oh that was nuts
right there I thought um Oh back to
tournament okay that's what I needed I
definitely needed that being down on
being down a couple of minutes and this
guy right here is the one that I was
trying to catch in that one in that one
tournament right at the last second I
ended up catching this guy can I catch
him again we will see we will see okay
here we go the one minute ones I'm
liking the one minute ones better than
the two minute ones I see more hope for
comebacks in the one minute ones sneak a
bunch of games and are they gonna take
my pawn yet alright now I'm gonna take
theirs I think they they don't get
compensation out if you wait too long
and I get more development in they don't
get enough compensation so mmm h 2 is
covered they're insisting on getting at
that point but if um what I'm not gonna
take that whoa whoa whoa what is going
on here against my king they're trying
to kill me here are you definitely
trying to kill me but I guess I'm
killing their bishop now is Knight here
good oh oh oh oh am I in trouble are
they gonna remove a defender just take
that and then oh man well let's hit the
Queen there we go now this is this is
this is good Queen c2 check this is
leading to no not quite me if the bishop
locks its Knight here that's a cool mate
bishop lock yes I'll take it
smothered mate 11 10 10 6 4 here we go
a lot of time left we got three games in
so far well two in a resigner did I
already just play this guy was this the
last guy that I just played are they
paired up but we're paired up again
okay knight c6 I should have run what
the e6 move maybe
okay and session of cops is Cillian what
next dream of that okay now this is on
and I could get d5 in e4 is under fire
and I'm gonna take with my knight and
now I'm gonna change the structure I
think this is a good structure to be
running with and I'm winning upon now
they were in check and this move is not
good until I Castle until I Castle here
now f5 maybe what that's just a piece
that was a miscalculation I'm on there
bishop
okay keep things simple keep my bishop
connected get primo of this get my king
to d6 King to d6 into d6 keep the
tension there's no um okay I'm alright
with that break up these ponds and I'll
get that pond back okay so this is still
one more trades coming up I want to play
this and then get the pawn okay now my
king has to come all the way over here
to do that then get back over here push
my passed pawn quickly very quickly get
it as far as Vance as I could and and
then come back in this direction over
here these pawns are gonna be gobbled up
take my bishop I get a queen quickly
give a check and go for me soon okay
back to tournament they were down on
time nineteen eighteen eighteen that guy
is in first place still the one that I
caught the one time let's go here let's
go let's go let's move that and then
this and then maybe do a quick capture
maybe they won't suspect it let's do
that
c4 okay now what are they gonna do
Bishop Bishop f5 might be good okay it
still might be good okay and now I'm
looking for a3 and b3 let's try it the
a3 and b3 here oh I'm in a pin that's
difficult to get out of oh man
Bishop f3 okay I'm out of it I could get
out of it now get out of this pin
quickly wait a second how many times am
I gonna miss that move
I had it available forever I could take
there with check oh why didn't I do that
I'm gonna get my rook to c1 I want to
keep my rook on a to watch over my a
pond but I also want to watch over my
queen okay I wanna get this bead three
advance in can we please just get this
beat three advance in not quite my
knight is unprotected I need my king to
get over here
and now b3 is back on let's try it break
this down and then maybe even get Bishop
to b7 this should be seven but not so
fast I want to guard my seventh rank my
knight could be hit let's come over here
at a forty-five and maybe even g4g five
keep that night around maybe
okay back to tournament they're down on
time
twenty-nine twenty-eight once again this
guy has a one-point advantage here
one-point advantage okay
what do we got what do we got they're
gonna take my knight all right they're
gonna get to this square now b6 with
check if they Castle I got this pawn now
you know the Knights hit if it attacks
me whoa wait a second let's do this I'm
on the bishop and then the knight
miscalculation my knights protected also
on the edge my queen is in a really
strong post Bishop g4 would have been
better I'm on the okay this is a
crumbling now for my opponent I'm on the
rook they can't leave defense of the
rook the left defense of the rook
another check and this is leading to
mate soon
Turner era not tournament over they
resigned 4840 that guy must have he's
still a game ahead but there's still
a lot of time 19 minutes it's a 30
minute tournament so we're not even
halfway there 19 minutes 48 40:28 it's
between us two again we will see come on
just pair me up with somebody if I get
paired up with this guy that'll be a
very big game
what there's others 22 players in this
tournament right now average rating is
1832 any day now any day this one's done
and come on what's going on nobody else
is available to play you kidding me um
what other games are going on okay no
time to look at him oh this guy is neck
and neck with me he has uh he has 40 as
well they're doing this Hedgehog type of
thing I want to get that on this f6
squared under my control I'm gonna drop
that pun that's all right
hopefully okay let's get this in and
give up my dark square Bishop to get my
knight here if the pawn pushes I get a
fork okay there we go got the fork and
let's open up some files are they gonna
open up files for me I work themselves
into a pin maybe get rid of that light
square bishop before bad things happen
and what next
take here I have everything defended
Queen Shak let's do this and this what's
the plan here let's run to this square
not the safest thing to be doing here
okay rook here I'm in a pin but I'm
looking for clean here next or that this
is much more simple now simpler to make
pre moves in this situation and now I'll
get behind this pawn and then work on my
King improvement
okay they drop that I got this or I'm
the same files everything resigned 54
what's the leaders 64-54 he's got a
10-point lead when I went out on no I
wouldn't point out on tiebreaks 1863
1861 I think the higher the number the
better you have with tiebreaks not
certain of that I'm assuming that's how
it would run let me close out of this
why am I not getting paired up gambler
here we go
I could really use a fast resigner here
let's try this for a change and then the
Queen c7 and since try b5 and okay now
let's put pressure on that night and
let's get my other night over here to
get that Bishop and I have control over
e5 they don't have the f4 move in I
think things are good maybe Bishop d6
would have been a strong move as well
I'm still looking for maybe d5 let's do
rip to c8 first and then Knight to e5 to
c4 Knight e5 2 c4 avoid Knight exchanges
and pawn push if the knight is pinned
maybe I'm ok with double pawns I have
the D file to work with my dark square
bishop springs to life f2 could be a
problem Bishop Queen b6 Bishop to c5
stuff against c2 as well where does the
knight go I'm going to hit the clean or
maybe not
let's see the knight has to move where's
it gonna go they're burning a lot of
time 24 23 22 seconds for them they're
not moving why are they not moving f2
now I can also take on c2 but I'm seeing
something maybe good with just
pinpointing f2 doubling up on the D file
the Queen is actually running out of
squares where does the Queen go I think
I want to insert h6 that was the only
square available for the Queen that's
reasonable so clean here check I guess
they're gonna throw that in Bishop here
or I could have just taken the Queen
okay they're down on time anyhow back to
turn with 80 to 70 twelve points ahead
come on I'm not making up any ground why
am I not making up any ground on that
guy
that's not the first time I made that
mouse slip either I won dude efore I
wanted to do a four there and let's get
this out I'm gonna get him get pushed
around now pawn push if not I'll just
play d5 uh-oh seventh rank and diagonals
are weakened now with that move I might
want to throw this in-between move and
but no not quite because there's a queen
check and I end up having to give up
something I think pawn push let's
challenge it I'm trying to break down
this pawn and Knight c3 I could add more
fuel to it let's let's see if they're
gonna cave in here and help me out with
my development okay now this is back on
I'm seeing maybe an eventual pin
eventual pin of their queen coming up
Castle I take a couple times Bishop to
c4 now I just stopped from castling
Knight to a5 might be necessary and I
might just let my darks were my light
square bishop sit there and if they're
gonna take I have two pawns to be
working with but now I want to preserve
my bishop they're playing b5 I want to
back up I'm not sure if there's a big
difference between B 3 or a 2 and I
could get this pawn I'm going to target
that I'm not quite sure how and actually
they could be getting this pawn oops
are they gonna do it no okay oh yeah I'm
seven seconds seven seconds I'm just
gonna pre move that they don't have time
to do anything and just premium another
check okay back to Turman 88 82
overtaking can I maintain it though oh
this guy result or not he didn't resign
he had disconnected my opponent it's
saying that there will be a reconnection
in 56 seconds maybe they're going to be
forfeited in the exact time that you're
seeing tick away right now so in the
meantime let me pre move this or let's
let's go with that and in case they jump
back in and let's see what's going on
elsewhere
and let's see the guy that could maybe
be catching me is where where's his game
ad something or other had fall where is
he
let me go back to the leaders this guy a
DAV where's that game not seeing it
a DAV not seeing it I guess it's not up
it maybe he's waiting for a game this
guy right here is maybe pretty close to
he's got 52 points
it looks like White's gonna be dead and
black is winning again okay
I gotta go back to my game it's starting
in a couple seconds three seconds back
to tournament got another win leaders at
this point 102 oh he has one or two and
I have 98 now and this is the guy this
is a leader I gotta win this game if I
don't win this game that's it the
Queen's are off okay this is a quick one
I got oh let's not give oh I wanted to
not do that move I get that LightSquared
bishop and I want to do what next oh man
this is tough this is real tough here
get my king up to this square I think
this is a good spot and my rook here I
feel like I'm about to miss something
let's kick this night away
can I put pressure on their King I have
to dodge check hopefully I have
everything covered here okay I'm looking
for tricks take here check I got so I
got a pond at least at least a pond and
what next
oh there's Forks available let's take
here and then guard this pond and then
get over here Knight takes is covered
Knight takes is covered I could be
getting this
uh-oh Forks it's looking good they only
have 20 seconds if they defend their
pond let's get some trades here I'm on
this I missed twice I think this is good
I have that Knight pinned
um what am I missing
I'm gonna get now let's not go there I
just want to trade what am i doing
it's just trade please let's just raid
here get my rub back here and then it's
a trade here I'm gonna throw in a check
they don't have any time they don't have
any time oh no I don't want to do that
what's what's this clothes I can't move
what clothes this allow what is going
out of my screen oh wait they resigned I
can't get rid of this though what's
going on with my screen Oh what's going
on okay
Oh deny or something I can't get this
thing out of here somebody help of
technical issues what's going on here I
can't get rid of it why am I not able to
click on things
do I have to refresh my screen is that
would I be forfeited I got to try
something um leave this page what I
could be able to get back into the
tournament
pair me back up maybe it's just saying
I'm been disconnected go go go go go
come on let's go let's go let's go I
have no idea what happened okay I'm back
in here I only have 18 seconds oh my
goodness I have to pre move like crazy
here oh my goodness I don't have
anything now are they gonna take my
night okay I don't have any time the
night's gonna take I got to throw a
check-in I really just have to pre move
like literally everything here okay
queenside castle I'm gonna pre move this
pretty move a take are they gonna okay
I'm just gonna block a check they might
push their pond they might take my queen
16 seconds get my knight here get my
king off with this same file quickly or
maybe they're gonna take my knight no my
queen is hit offer Queen exchange 14
seconds I'm coming back actually burning
time I don't want to hit my eye right
mouse-click that
ridiculous I don't know why why I
couldn't like figure that one out
trade Queens I'm catching back up a time
oh they didn't go for that trade I want
to take this pawn and be on their queen
I'm gonna do it anyhow
in between move o h7 h7 h7 is on I have
to defend against b7 e7 will stay at my
queen might have to come all the way
back
oh let's come all the way back to the
rescue two seconds cream of this they're
out of time back to tournament oh here
we go here we go here we go another I
couldn't see whose arm I have no idea
where we are in the standings I wasn't
able to look the past couple of past
couple ones this is ridiculous okay
Bishop to d3 Queen c2 castle and get my
knight up and follow up with f4 let's
get this trade in though and I might
want to just give that Knight up yeah
let's just give that up and work on this
F file maybe if that Knight moves I got
h7 I want to get rid of that clean how
could I get rid of that Queen get my
knight involved here we go Knight coming
to f5 my queen coming to f2 ready to
take the knight Oh F farm is on Knight
to d6 this has to be strong hitting the
Queen rook g3 I'm on g7 Knight h6 stuff
this is a check there's got to be
another check here there's got to be
mate something
where's there mate let's hit this
looking to smash through at that point
if you have another check and get my
rook to f7 I'm on this and then this
this is me this is leading to me if
Knight takes otherwise what is there
there's Bishop g6 discovered check or is
there actually my rook would be hanging
I got a I gotta go with this let's do
that
and oh why did they go with that looking
for f7 now can I get F 7 check and then
looking for mate next on each 5 each 5
looking for me
pawn push I just take and still it's on
how many seconds left
oh ok over here is good h6 now is the
move and it can't be stopped
back to tournament how much time 138 136
minutes left
woo okay it's very close 138 130 106 103
I cannot be clicking on I can't right
mouse click and get any anymore here
that's how that little thing came up
that was bad I'm glad my opponent
resigned that game too I wasn't able I
would have been able to figure it out I
would have ended up losing on time if
they didn't resign I dodged a bullet in
the bullet game okay get my Knights
connected this is a theme that keeps
showing up oh I can't do that right away
I need my knight to get back to full
strength here or in other words get it
unpinned and let's play here before that
bishop cements itself on d6 and I'm
looking to shut down that light square
bishop oh what's going on with this I
have enough defense
there's no way to attack my bishop again
rook taking here is that gonna be a
problem
the bishop is dead quick resigner I need
a like a one-game lead to be a bit more
comfortable here okay we're back on with
time let's have that pawn push I want to
secure my Knights position let's get
castled Knight here is gonna be pretty
good or Bishop to f5 and I here looks
pretty good targeting C to its target c2
again hit twice defended zero can't be
defended again you're still getting it
and I'm gonna oh they missed that their
clean is almost acting just like a
bishop right now let's just come back
here smash open their Kings side just
come here defend the pawn again and
chase that night away maybe 24 seconds
my knight has that square available
don't really want to give up my dark
square bishop so I look to EA and get
another piece working less than 10
seconds for my opponent what's this
queen doing what is she up to
she might be targeting this soon I'll
take that night if so let's just take
that I don't want to deal with it more
trades oh there goes my night they're
back I'm back to tournament thou 158 140
have a little bit a little bit of a
cushion right here that was weird
that was weird that little thing that
came up there let's close out of that
are they gonna pair me up two more games
maybe we both have 14 games in oh he
just overtook me right here 162 158 come
on pair me up I gotta fight back again
let's go here let's go I need to aah
let's go with this man I can't even move
let's go let's go let's get the dark red
bishops off I want my knight on e5 there
we go
tonight heading for a 5 how many mouse
lives can you make in a game oh my
goodness how many mouse slips can there
be count them up
I want that c4 pawn ok let's let's guard
this and target that e pond there we go
it's got to be good yes click resign
come on you know you want to resign
let's hit this Queen maybe Queen to h5
okay I'm gonna take this come on
discover checks let's grab this and then
do what next secure that point free move
that this and then get my pawn rollin
and rollin and he's gone far enough
ah no what
this my bishop should be here are they
looking for a stalemate I'm not gonna
los tell me I'm looking for mate now
there we go that's a cute mate I'll take
it back to tournament 178 man but I
think every game he's winning he's
getting 20 points so if he's winning his
next game he's gonna be two points ahead
H fun H pun there we go H pawn attack
get that light square Bishop out of
there and get my queen up here we go
give a check okay let's get my knight
here
darks for a bishop up I like my knight
too much let's come back maybe they'll
play rook takes pawn
am I missing anything pawn push it's a
key that Queen Castle queenside and then
play this pawn move okay that's uh
there's got to be something here right
Queen c6 Queen c6 where can my dark
square Bishop be let's try it here maybe
this move oh the Queen is pinned now our
unprotected excuse me so I could take I
should have maybe played that instead my
life dark square bishop could see Queen
here that's not quite working mm-hmm my
pieces aren't quite moving oh man oh I
could have taken that pawn yeah check I
want to save that for some reason I
think they could be missing that
particular move I could have taken
oh wait what's going on here I could
have taken that pawn for a while is this
mate no it's not me a block are they
gonna just resign oh they felt that they
had to give up their queen let's do this
and then I'm taking that pond next maybe
okay I'm on this and I got the rook if
they take my bishop after it
Queen to d1 Shak
I got the rook resign I just want to
throw in some quick moves and just take
care even though that's probably a
loosening idea
okay back to tournament 198 to 186
seconds if I have it there it is right
at the last second actually that was
another nail-biter oh man there was only
six seconds left I did it with six
seconds to spare on that one I'll take
it I'll take that one
Wow once again neck-and-neck with this
guy right here I'm gonna have to look
back at that one that was that was wacky
right there with that little thing
coming up I got it I got a plan for that
one that's a move you don't plan for a
chest right there a little technical
difficulties the unchaste related
details good games